first off hello and congratulations love
the movie Belle I wanted to start with
you on this one because I was reading
that it was your first improvised
audition so can you break that process
down for us a little and you know what
happened to do it was really scary
and so I've been given the scene like
before like said in a scene I think it
was like a scene when they were in the
restaurant or something but I've been
told like don't worry about don't worry
about like learning the lines because I
don't want to see if you can't like do
stuff like you couldn't provide the
basically so then I went in to audition
and we did that and it felt like I
obviously like like we knew the CEO had
some ideas in my head so I like okay and
then here Lee another lunch on the spot
was like oh here read this and I was
like yeah and then he was like but don't
worry about the lines just like get the
situation and just like kind of make it
up and so yeah and so then it provides
that to with Pete which is like also
because like we knew each other before
but then we were like we might really
like wakefulness it is very strange and
but it already pretty well right well I
think very much so and then a big time
to the actual final feature for both of
you what advice would you give to
another actor who's about to work with
Judd for the very first time to make the
most of the experience I would say like
in terms of the improv just don't be
scared to fail like it with that
honeymoon prize Asian if you're like
constantly thinking like am i funny like
are people laughing at me like if you're
a it's you in your own head and you're
not gonna be able to like nosedive into
it in a good way
you're not gonna be able to like jump in
headfirst literally what I was thinking
like staying present in the moment and I
mean at least for me because I always
I'm overthinking everything like you
just kind of don't have the time to be
doing that when you're improvising so
you have to stay super present so Maude
I did want to ask you about something
that I was reading that you said that
may
he does represent you know always
overthinking and it was what you said
about always needing to prove yourself
and never to stop that fight and I very
much respect the sentiment but you've
also accomplished a lot in your own
right over the years so I was wondering
is there any kind of I don't know like a
bucket list item that when you tick that
box
you yourself are gonna feel like you've
proven yourself I mean to you more yeah
I don't know that's a tricky one because
I'm just I mean I don't say this without
sounding like emo but I've just always
been pretty hard on myself and but I
think that like most people that I
talked to who are in this industry like
it's important to kind of think that way
and like you never can settle like he
just got to keep going and like yeah I
mean I don't know maybe but I actually I
don't think so I'm a big fat hypocrite
cuz I got the same exact thought process
so I was looking for you to give me an
answer
because I am a big fan of tattoos and I
love what they mean in this movie for
both of you do you have tattoos and if
you don't what would you get and why I
don't have any I'm so boring I know the
game said that I totally would get one I
just never come across the one that I
would get yeah I don't know what I just
said I never come across it and there's
no onsen so hard because I feel like
tattoos like once you start getting a
lot of tattoos you become like more
comfortable like just I don't know like
not having them maybe mean as much or
like I just I would overthink it so my
October thinking but I follow this
Korean tattoo artists on Instagram who
does like these tiny little like you can
send a picture of your family or like a
picture of your pets and he'll draw them
and they're just like very like little
and sweet and I would got not maybe of
my cat I don't know if that's weird
if I have a tattoo of my cotton 20 years
but alive or something I don't know what
it's worth you suggesting that makes me
want to immediately find that okay I've
been looking for the knife I will send
it along as we wind down here Maude I
can't let you get away without a
euphoria question because I know Sam
wrote the part of Lexi for you so what's
your collaboration been like on season
two in her arc there because you were
such a big influence so are you guys
kind of working together to develop
where she's going from here um I think
so
I mean Sam like I always knew that I
didn't have much of an arc in season one
and that it was coming in season two and
so we when Sam was writing had a few
like long conversations about just like
where things could go and I think he had
a pretty good idea of where I could go
but we definitely collaborated a lot and
he's super open to listening to what all
of us as actors have to say about our
characters which makes it a lot of it's
it's really nice when people are open to
that I can't wait to see what you guys
bring in season two and now please
excuse me cuz I'm gonna go stalk your
Instagram and look for that